ich sag das immer alles halb so wild
zumindest nach dem siebten glühwein und
gerade weil die letzten monate so
unglaublich giftig und polarisierend
waren weil deutschland so gespalten ist
wie nie zuvor kann man noch wegen zu
weihnachten mal das positive sehen ja
parlamentarische demokratie ist manchmal
mühselig langsam aber sie ist mit
abstand das beste was wir haben
natürlich klingt es vielleicht ein tick
heuchlerisch wenn die sendung wie unsere
sagt das sagt aber schreiben sie ihren
abgeordneten doch mal eine nette
weihnachtskarte und bedanken sich für
seinen oder ihren einsatz
mainz völlig ernst denn ohne diese leute
oder ohne menschen die sich tatsächlich
freiwillig um kommunalpolitik kümmern
selbst unser system gar nicht und wenn
dieses komische fest weihnachten einen
sinn hat also jenseits von alkohol dann
dass man sich zusammenrauft für die paar
stunden muss doch möglich sein
das war das wort zum sonntag gleich
kommt der satirische jahresrückblick wir
sehen uns am 27 januar
[Musik]
ein fehler
fr
anschlag
oh ja
auch sein
[Musik]
deuce
rückschlag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr
[Musik]
so wie
[Applaus]